par maître vergès interposés klaus
barbie une fois de plus met en cause
raymond aubrac et cela dans la sphère de
cas lui hier raymond aubrac était le
responsable du groupe libération
il est furieux et indigné que l'on
s'attaque de nouveau ainsi à la
résistance dans son ensemble d'autant
ajoutent ils que maître vergès qu'il
avait déjà dit femme et a été condamné
pour cela
isabelle bechler klaus barbie l'avait
dit avec ce sourire sarcastique qu'on
découvrait sur son visage le premier
jour de son procès à lyon il allait
bouleverser l'image de la résistance et
mettrait en cause des héros au dessus de
tout soupçon
l'ancien chef de la gestapo de lyon
vient dans une audition du juge a ni de
revenir sur la sphère de caluire celle
de la réunion de la résistance chez le
docteur dugoujon le 21 juin 43 jours où
la gestapo arrêté jean moulin sur
renseignement mais renseignements de qui
on s'en souvient
monsieur redit vous ne deviez pas être à
cette réunion à caluire comment vous
avez fort aux compagnons de résistance
on dit que ce jour là vous ne deviez pas
être à caluire comment expliquez-vous
que vous y étiez
jusqu'au va demander dit rien je vais
vous aviez oui j'étais à lâcher comme
monsieur aubry ailleurs comme beaucoup
d'autres imaginez comment est-ce que
c'est justement sur ces informations là
que barbie revient aujourd'hui selon son
avocat depuis mai 43 on sait qu'il y a
dans la direction de l'armée secrète un
traître et que se traite ne peut pas
être hardy qui sera arrêté seulement le
9 juin
ça c'est dans leurs ports kaltenbrunner
de mecs 1943 qui on sait déjà très long
sur l'armé secrète
aujourd'hui barbie rappelle qu'il n'a
pas traité tous ces prisonniers de
caluire de la même manière et pour cause
selon lui comment barbie opéré puisque
parmi les neuf personnes il va
transférer ce fait à transférer six par
train à paris
il va accompagner en voiture et en civil
jean moulin et il va garder deux des
neuf personnes arrêtées à lyon rené
hardy et monsieur raymond aubrac
indignation de raymond aubrac et son
épouse résistantes ou deux qui ont déjà
gagné un procès en diffamation contre m
vergès en tout cas ce vergès qui avait
plein de choses dans sa musette et la
met du temps à les sortir et barbie à
avoir de la mémoire personnage qui a
envoyé des gosses au crématoire à
auschwitz et qui continue maintenant
faire le même boulot du fond de sa
prison
quand même un peu exaspérant on peut
faire dire n'importe quoi à barbie il a
rien à perdre qui peut se venger il peut
aider ses amis ses amis à se venger eux
mêmes
il peut aussi essayer de digérer l'échec
qu'il a subie quand lucie attaqués sont
en groupe on peut utiliser ce bar mines
qui est au fond de sa prison peuvent
utiliser pour n'importe quoi et il ya
fort à parier que 15 barbie pendant le
procès qui l'attend sera de l'épisode de
caluire leur de toutes les trahisons